Democrats in the media never took Trump
seriously in 2016 remember when the
Huffington Post moved their Trump
coverage to the entertainment section
but then he defeated crooked Hillary and
the rest history now former Senate
Majority Leader Harry Reid is warning
his fellow Democrats again
never underestimate Donald Trump I don't
think he's intellectually a powerhouse
but he is basically a very very smart
man he no matter what the subject any
argument he involves himself in it's on
his terms
anyone that thinks tones gonna be beaten
easily should have another thing coming
meanwhile comedian Bill Maher's sounding
the alarm on Biden's ability to defeat
Trump I've always said I like Joe he'd
never mind my favorite but if he's the
guy to beat Trump I was like let's not
kill him because if he's the one but I
must say my confidence that he can beat
Trump is waning he looks like a
depreciating stock to me I'm not trying
to get Joe out but the we do need
someone in the center yes who say
younger and female are female although
very unhealthy for Democrats to
underestimate Donald Trump I think the
media is responsible because they
portray him as always you know hanging
by his fingertips off the edge of a
cliff when in reality it's not like that
I spent Thursday night and Friday night
sitting in the chair with makeup on an
attire I'm waiting for Hannity to come
to me when the president was having a
rally in first in Minnesota in
Minneapolis and then in Lake Charles
Louisiana and watching it I could see
this was a great TV show and that crowd
was so robust they were so enthusiastic
I'm telling you no Democrat could match
that enthusiasm even with Beyonce they
couldn't get that kind of a crowd and
keep that crowd for as long as he did he
had them spellbound he's a he's a master
performer and I think that watching him
and then weighing him against the
candidates on the Democratic side you
know there's plenty of issues against
the president don't get me wrong but in
terms of sheer exuberance and and power
of his personality he's gonna be
extremely formidable and all these
reporters there they're embedded at
these campaign rallies they see the
gee they see the electricity are they
denying it or what is the deal let me
tell you watching these rallies and I've
been in a few of them watching the Dems
are petrified because the enthusiasm
that the president Garner's is
unparalleled no one can do what he does
and so they can talk until the cows come
home
nothing's gonna change and that's why
they have to impeach him to beat him
they knew it from the get-go but the
shame of it is that the American public
is saying look if you want to impeach
him okay but make it fair and so
everything is gonna boo meringue it's a
boomerang you think it's gonna be 2016
all over again potentially well I think
that he'll survive impeachment if they
decide to do it and then then he's
really a lot stronger and Harry Reid is
a very savvy politician he has been
actually pushing for Elizabeth Warren
there's been bullish he's been bullish
on Elizabeth Warren for a long time he
knows that's a swing state that's a
really important one that the president
would like to try to get and did they
get it you talk about in the bond excuse
me I was thinking of a New Mexico nearby
but if I was really interested in the
Bill Maher piece there's just no
enthusiasm or bacon everybody's trying
to gently say even like all the former
Obama people there's no real enthusiasm
for him and yet as I said on Friday like
his he actually holds up pretty well in
the polls
yes he's hung on in a pretty weak field
to that number one position Greg well
the dams used to push and granny off a
cliff so this is their that they're
slowly trying to get by not there no
people often mean by that what do you
mean by that
remember that old commercial never the
campaign ad of the Paul Ryan air it
wasn't all it was a stupid tangent on my
part people often ask me though Jessie
how did I get so successful and as being
a world-class Everett and I say it
wasn't by under estimating anything I
overestimate everything if I have a nine
o'clock p.m. flight I show up at 8:00
p.m. the day before but I underestimate
all the problems I'm a neurotic
you overestimate all the problems no way
yes my point is this my point is that
the
you can despise Trump and hate how he
talks of course it's but you can't deny
the electricity of those of those
rallies the problems with the Dems
instead of learning from that
relationship they decided to say oh well
they're all deplorable - I hate Trump I
hate these people rather than saying
what is going on here that we don't have
it's a huge mistake to just say all of
these people suck because I feel sorry
for Joey I mean every every parent
particularly with multiple children has
had problems with I do feel sorry
because he did serve the country since a
China on Air Force - yeah you know what
happened to it did real well when he got
to the White House and he made sure his
family did his son thing President
Obama's tushie was extraordinary well it
was horrifying to many but I had to lap
in there